my goal is to give this person power  what are the things or the frameworks we  think about to get to yes and the yes  that i want from somebody is not a yes  i'm going to buy but yes i'm going to  decide and i think if you can delineate  that for yourself too it takes a little  bit of the pressure off selling because  my goal is to give this person power and  you have to understand what power is in  order to give it so the dictionary  definition  is the ability to influence or direct  events or people that's the dictionary  definition as i see omnipotence so god  or a god figure would be as they think  it appears so the distance between  thoughts and reality there is no  distance right that would be an  omnipotent being if he thinks the world  exists and so as we take steps towards  that is the ideal we become more  powerful and if we can do that for our  prospects we can allow them to step into  the person they want to be and make a  decision to own their [ __ ] one way or  another